do you know about the georgia
guidestones have you ever heard about
the georgia guidestones i had heard
about them
but until just a couple of days ago i
had kind of forgotten about them because
the georgia guidestones are this bizarre
stonehenge-like structure that was
erected in the late 1970s in georgia and
no one really knows who was behind it
and then a couple of days ago they got
blown up and we don't know who blew them
up
so if this was erected in 1979
and the reason people are are interested
in the georgia guidestones is because it
seems kind of
occult
seems kind of conspiratorial
new world ordery there are a lot of
conspiracies surrounding them or
conspiracy theories quote unquote it's
probably conspiracies too in in june
1979
a guy using the pseudonym robert c
christian
approached the elberton granite
finishing company
anonymously or pseudonymously and he
said that a small group of loyal
americans wanted to erect this structure
and so the the granite company said okay
and they gave him a ridiculously high
number for the cost because they thought
it was bizarre and they didn't want to
do it and then the secret society said
okay that's fine that's fine don't worry
that cost is fine and then they went out
and bought a bunch of land and they
erected this bizarre stonehenge-like
structure on there and they had
ten commandments on there but they're
not the normal ten commandments they're
not the christian ten commandments they
were kind of
anti-anti-commandments
here's what they said first one
maintain humanity under 500 million in
perpetual balance with nature
500 million how many people do we have
right now
8 billion or something maybe more
maintain 500 million that means you'd
have to eradicate the vast majority of
the world population
guide reproduction wisely improving
fitness and diversity so that's just
eugenics that just means kill off the
weak
kill off the the inferior races and make
sure you improve the fitness of the race
unite humanity with a living new
language that's some weird babylon kind
of stuff rule passion faith tradition
and all things with tempered reason
i sounds like kind of weird
enlightenment secret society kind of
talk we need to subdue faith and passion
and tradition with our reason with our
age of enlightenment reason
protect people and nations with fair
laws and just core it's okay i support
that that sounds good
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court
okay i'm halfway on board with that i
like ruling internally and i like some
diplomacy but what is this world court
are we talking about a kind of one-world
government here avoid petty laws and
useless officials yep sounds good to me
balanced personal rights with social
duties okay prize truth beauty love
seeking harmony with the infinite
so i yeah okay that's fine yeah the
first part's definitely fine what this
language though of the infamous it
sounds
it sounds like the weird esoteric
language of those secret societies that
cropped up during the enlightenment and
that have wreaked a lot of havoc on
civilization and then be not a cancer on
the earth leave room for nature
leave room
for nature
and be not a cancer on the earth well
that sounds like what the left believes
the left believes that human beings are
a kind of a cancer that's why they're so
worried about overpopulation like these
people are they're so worried about our
horrible effect killing the environment
we humans we're the problem we're the
disease
we must we must return to nature and
allow nature to heal by killing
ourselves and not having any kids
it's weird it's creepy it's
it has the language of secret societies
and new age cults and all sorts of stuff
that i don't like
the georgia guidestones were bad
i am glad that they are gone
i don't know how they were destroyed was
it someone affiliated with the stones
that destroyed them i guess probably not
was an act of vandalism there have been
acts of vandalism there before i don't i
don't support breaking the law but i'm
glad they're gone they're bad monuments
they
speak to a false religion and i'm glad
that they're no longer there okay and
that's as simple as that
it's bad stuff i was reminded i was
reading last night hillary bellock and
he he was such a clear thinker he was a
historian uh he was a catholic writer he
wrote a lot about religion
he just reminds me and and this is
something that we've got to remind
ourselves pretty regularly
the fundamental
distinction
among all the people of the world is not
race it's really not yes races have
differences and
different cultures and different
geographies but
that's not the fundamental distinction
the fundamental distinction among human
beings is not even sex men and women are
totally different they're complementary
but that's not really what separates us
it's religion it's not nationality it's
not politics it's not it's it's religion
ultimately because religion
even if you don't think you're religious
even if you don't go to church even if
you don't think that you're practicing
rituals
you are everything comes out of religion
because
any way you act in the world you've got
to have some sense of what is right and
wrong and what is true and who you are
and what your place is in the world and
what we're all here for and what you're
even doing and what you even want all of
that ultimately has to come from
religion
politics is not going to suffice science
is not going to suffice those are all
category errors okay they're not going
to answer the biggest questions only
religion can do that
and it's it's very bad
when
we when our religious monuments every
every society has religious monuments
there is has never ever been in all of
human history a total separation between
religion and the state can't happen
it's very bad when our public religious
symbols
are
false and wrong and
lead to destruction we have religious
symbols all over our society we just
don't totally recognize them as such the
rainbow flag is a religious symbol that
makes totally moral claim well immoral
claims but it may but it's making claims
about morality the georgia guidestones
are
are religious symbols
more explicitly religious symbols there
have been
secret societies in american history
that have wreaked a great great deal of
wrought a great deal of havoc there was
even at one point in america there was
an anti-mason party that's how prominent
the secret societies were okay and
people will call you a conspiracy
theorist when you point out hey these
georgia guidestones are kind of weird
well
it's it's not some random theory it's
not a tin foil somebody put them up
these these sorts of movements and
esoteric societies they do exist they do
believe things they are pushing an
agenda some are less hidden than others
some are right out there in public
that's not a conspiracy theory that's a
conspiracy
and
when conspiracies are are allowed to
flourish and they're against the
national interest it's good when they
get stopped okay that's i'm not going to
complain that the creepy weird cult
guidestones
were taken down
right now go to epicwill.com use promo
code knowles did you know this is an
interesting fact did you know that 100
of people who skydive will die
did you know that also 100 of people who
breathe will die it's gonna happen no
one here gets out alive man not not on
this earth not in this world okay
so whether you're gonna jump out of an
airplane at fifteen thousand feet or
you're just gonna go quietly in your
sleep either way you're gonna need a
will all right best way to get a will go
to epic will right now your will is not
about you your will is about your loved
ones and the very difficult decisions
that they will face
if and when something happens to you
decisions such as whether to keep you on
life support or not whether to bury you
or cremate you if you are a parent you
definitely don't want a judge deciding
who should step in and raise your kids
just some bureaucrat comes in and says
okay your kid's gonna be raised by
so-and-so no don't do that go to
epicwill.com use promo code knowledge if
10
on epic will's complete will package
epic will can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes super easy
well worth 119 dollars to secure your
family's future no matter where you're
at in life 14 000 feet in the air or
right here on the ground you need to
have a will go to epicwheel.com use
promo code knowles today
i'm glad you like that clip guys i am so
close to 1 million youtube subscribers
and you know what's going to happen
i'm going to get a million youtube's not
going to be happy about that they're
probably going to completely nuke my
account well bring it on baby that's
what i say i'm an accelerationist when
it comes to youtube please subscribe
ring the bell
send this to your friends text it email
it carrier pigeon we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you